[موسيقى]
الأحاسيس التي أشعر بها في عجلة القيادة
من السيارة
الأول والأكثر أهمية ل
لي أن لدي انطباع لا
لم يتم تعطيل ليكون مثل
كنت من قبل
[موسيقى]
اسمي فريدريك سوسيت وأنا كذلك
سائق سباق السيارات
وقع حادثتي في يوليو 2012
لقد أصبت ببكتيريا
لخدش في إصبع وهذا
لم يتم الكشف عن البكتيريا
ما يكفي من السعادة وكان
تحولت إلى البرق و تعفن الدم
لقد فقدت ذراعي ورجلي
عندما أدركت حالتي
كانت بالفعل صدمة لكن الحقيقة
أن أكون محاطًا جيدًا ولكن حقًا
ساعدنا حقًا في البقاء على قيد الحياة على أي حال
وابدأ حياة جديدة
قبل حادثتي لم أقود سيارتي قط
لطالما كنت متحمسًا للرياضة
السيارات منذ الصغر
لكن لم يكن لدي وقت لذلك
ممارسة رياضة السيارات وعندما يكون لدي
تعرضت لهذا الحادث الذي احتجت إليه
تجد في تحد لا يصدق
غير ممكن
بهدف نهائي هو الوصول إلى 24
ساعات لو مان لأي رياضة
مستوى الحاجة إلى التدريب
خاصة لي مع إعاقتى
كان لدي برنامج لمدة 24 ساعة
أكثر من ثلاث ساعات في اليوم
كان هناك برنامج إدارة الصناديق
تم تطويره عن طريق التعبير عن الباقي
معدات محددة أستطيع
تسريع مع فخذي الأيمن و
فريدريك فخذي الأيسر وعجلة القيادة
محددة مع بدلة بالكاد
بعد عامين ونصف كنت في البداية
24 ساعة من لو مان
إنه تتويج في حياة أ
طيار للقاء في 24 ساعة من
مان ولي حتى لو كان لدي بالفعل
تمكنت من القيام بذلك لا يزال حلما
افعلها مرة أخرى لأنها شيء ما
لا يصدق تماما
[موسيقى]
الهدف حقًا هو التنافس معه
يقودها الطيارون وهذا شيء
شيء مهم للغاية و
كان من المهم للغاية بالنسبة لي
شخصيا لإظهار أن
الإعاقة ليست غاية في حد ذاتها
لقد عملت بجد لإثبات ذلك
الإعاقة في مكانها في الرياضة
السيارة والرياضة عالية المستوى
سباق السيارات حيث تغير
كل حياتي الرسالة عندما هذين
خاصة أن يكون لديك حلم لأنه وحده
حلم نجذبنا إليه
إلى الأمام وانتقل بنا إلى
حياة جديدة
[موسيقى]